in March 2017 the mayor of Cape Town
officially declared Cape Town a local
disaster as it had less than four months
left of usable water residents were
restricted to a hundred liters of water
per person per day but what does that
really mean with a hundred litres of
water per day you could take a five
minute shower wash your face twice and
probably flush the toilet about five
times you still didn't brush your teeth
you didn't do laundry and you definitely
didn't water your plants you
unfortunately didn't wash your hands
after those five toilet flushes and you
didn't even take a sip of water
the mayor described this as that it
means a new relationship with water
today seven months later I can share two
things about my second home with you
first
Caitlin hasn't run out of water just yet
but as of September 3rd the hundred
reader limits dropped to 87 litres the
mayor defined the city's new normal as
one of permanent droughts second what's
happening in Cape Town is pretty much
coming to many other cities and
countries in the world according to the
Food and Agriculture Organization of the
United Nations excluding countries that
we don't have data for less than five
percent of the world's population is
living in a country that has more water
today than it did 20 years ago everyone
else is living in a country that has
less water today and nearly one out of
three are living in a country that is
facing a water crisis I grew up in
Jordan a water poor country that has
experienced absolute water scarcely
since 1973 and still in 2017 only 10
countries in the world have less water
than Jordan so dealing with a lack of
water is quite ingrained in my soul as
soon as I was old enough to learn how to
write my
I also learned that I need to conserve
water my parents would constantly remind
my siblings and I to close the tab when
we brush our teeth we used to fill
balloons with flour instead of water
when we play just as much fun though and
a few years ago when my friends and I
were dared to do the ice bucket
challenge we did that with sand and you
might think that you know that's easy
sand is not ice cold I promise you sand
goes everywhere and it took hey just to
get rid of it but what perhaps I didn't
realize as I played with flour balloons
as a child and as I poured sand on my
head as an adult is that some of the
techniques that seem second nature to me
and to others who live in dry countries
might help us all address what is fast
becoming a global crisis I wish to share
three lessons today three lessons from
water poor countries and how they
survived and even thrived despite their
water crisis lesson one tell people how
much water they really have in order to
solve a problem we need to acknowledge
that we have one and when it comes to
water people can easily turn a blind eye
pretending that this water's coming out
of the tap now everything will be fine
forever but some smart drought affected
countries have adopted simple innovative
measures to make sure their citizens
their communities and their companies
know just how dry their countries are
when I wasn't kaede-san earlier this
year I saw this electronic billboard on
the freeway indicating how much water
the city had left this is an idea they
may well have bored from Australia when
it faced one of the worst droughts of
the country's history from 1997 to 2009
water levels in Melbourne dropped a very
low capacity of almost 26 percent but
the city didn't yell at people
it didn't plead with them not to use
water they used electronic billboards
to slash available levels of water to
all citizens across the city
they were honestly telling people how
much water they really have and letting
them take responsibility for themselves
by the end of the drought this created
such a sense of urgency as well as a
sense of community nearly one out of
three citizens in Melbourne had invested
in installing rainwater holding tanks
for their own households actions the
citizens took didn't stop at installing
those tanks with help from the city they
were able to do something even more
impactful taking me to lesson to empower
people to save water
Melbourne wanted people to spend less
water in their homes and one way to do
that is to spend less time in the shower
however interviews revealed that some
people women in particular weren't keen
on saving water that way some of them
honestly said the shower is not just to
clean up it's my sanctuary it's a space
I go to relax not just clean up so the
city started offering water efficient
showerheads for free and then now some
people complain that the shower has
looked ugly or didn't suit their
bathrooms so what I like to call the
showerhead team developed a small water
flow regulator that can be fitted into
existing showerheads and although
showerhead Beauty doesn't matter much to
me but I loved how the team didn't give
up and instead came up with a simple
unique solution to empower people to
save water within a span of four years
more than 460,000 showerheads were
replaced when the small regulator was
introduced more than a hundred thousand
orders of that were done melbourne
succeeded in reducing the water demands
per capita by 50 percent in the united
arab emirates the second-most water
scarce country in the world
officials designed what they called the
business heroes toolkit in 2010 the aim
was to motivate and empower businesses
to reduce water and
energy consumption the toolkit
practically taught companies how to
measure their existing water consumption
levels and consisted of tips to help
them reduce those levels and it worked
hundreds of organizations downloaded the
toolkit and several of them joined what
they called the corporate heroes Network
where companies can voluntarily take on
a challenge to reduce their water
consumption levels to preset targets
within a period of one year companies
which completed the challenge saved on
average 35 percent of water and one
company for example they implemented as
many water saving tips as they could in
their office space they replaced their
toilet flushing techniques taps
showerheads you name it if it's saved
water they replaced it eventually
reducing their employees water
consumption by half empowering
individuals and companies to save water
is so critical yet not sufficient
countries need to look beyond the status
quo and implement country level actions
to save water taking me to lesson three
look below the surface water savings can
come from unexpected places Singapore is
the eighth most water scarce country in
the world it depends on imported water
for almost 60 percent of its water needs
it's also a very small island as such it
needs to make use of as much space
possible to catch rainfall so in 2008
they built the marina barrage it's the
first-ever urban water reservoir built
in the middle of the city-state
it's the largest water catchment in the
country almost 1/6 the size of Singapore
what's so amazing about the marina
barrage is that it has been built to
make the maximum use of its large size
and it's unexpected yet important
location it brings three valuable
benefits to the country it has boosted
Singapore's water supply by 10 percent
it protects low areas around it from
floods because of its connection to the
sea and as you can see it acts as a
beautiful lifestyle attraction hosting
several events from art exhibitions to
music festivals attracting joggers
bikers tourists all around that area
now not all initiatives need to be
stunning or even visible my first home
Jordan realized that agriculture is
consuming the majority of its work fresh
water they really wanted to encourage
farmers to focus on growing low water
intensive crops to achieve that the
local agriculture is increasing its
focus on date-palms and grapes those two
are much more tolerant to drought
conditions than many other fruits and
vegetables and at the same time they are
considered high-value crops both locally
and internationally locals in Namibia
one of the most arid countries in the
southern of Africa have been drinking
recycled water since 1968
now you may tell me in many countries
recycled water I will say yes but very
few use it for drinking purposes
mostly because people don't like the
thought of water that was in their
toilets going to their tubs but now
maybe I could not afford to think that
way they looked below the surface to
save water they are now a great example
of how when countries purify wastewater
to drinking standards they can ease
their water shortages and in the
mamiya's case provide drinking water for
more than 300,000 citizens in its
capital city as more countries which
used to be more water rich are becoming
water scarce I say we don't need to
reinvent the wheel if we just look at
what water poor countries have done the
solutions are out there now it's really
just up to all of us to take action
think
you
[Applause]